[Music]
on this tuesday night
the shake-up in justin trudeau's cabinet
bill morneau's abrupt departure and
christia freeland's rise
we can build back a country even better
than the one we had before the pandemic
hit us parliament's now paused
what it could mean for that ethics
investigation into the prime minister
fresh warning i never thought i would
get it a survivor's message to young
people who think they're immune to coven
19.
the campaign to rebuild beirut it was a
massacre it's a crime that happened
and the canadians helping during this
crisis
plus risky ride why this little boy took
a life or death decision
on a busy highway
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight
robin garrett
[Applause]
it's official canada has a new finance
minister
christia freeland has formally taken on
the role after bill moore knows sudden
resignation
she's the first woman in canadian
history to occupy this powerful position
good evening and thank you for joining
us morneau's departure less than 24
hours ago has set off a series of
fast-moving events in ottawa from the
cabinet changeup
to the move by prime minister justin
trudeau to pro-rogue parliament until
late september
trudeau says his government wants to lay
out a long-term pandemic recovery plan
and they plan to do that in a speech
from the throne
the throne speech will give us the
opportunity to lay out
in detail our approach going forward
it will also allow parliament to hold a
confidence vote
on this new plan there's a lot to cover
tonight from the strategy around that
confidence vote and how the opposition
is reacting
to what a pause in parliament means for
the ongoing we charity investigations
our coverage begins with our chief
political correspondent david aiken
on the choice of freeland as finance
minister
i face differently and with that toronto
mp christian freeland became the finance
minister
adding that title to another one she
already holds deputy prime minister
it's been nearly 20 years since any
cabinet minister held those two
positions simultaneously
but freelance admirers say she is
eminently qualified for the jobs
earning a reputation over the last five
years as a cabinet minister who gets
things done
most notably leading the successful
negotiations of the new nafta
now as the deputy pm finance minister
she's promising a transformative
economic recovery
i think all canadians understand that
the restart of our economy needs to be
green
it also needs to be equitable
details on that transformation will come
in a speech from the throne
to be delivered september 23rd until
then
parliament is pro-rogued suspended we
need to
reset the approach of this government
for a recovery to build
back better but opposition politicians
say the switch to freeland from the
resigning bill moreno
combined with proroguing parliament is a
cynical attempt by the pm
to turn the channel on trudeau's
perceived ethical failings in the we
charity matter it seems like the liberal
government is more interested in
throwing the finance minister
under the bus than the prime minister
taking responsibility for his own
breaches of the conflict
of interest laws in a statement andrew
scheer said
justin trudeau is walking out on
canadians in the middle of a major
health and economic crisis
in a disgusting attempt to make
canadians forget
about his corruption now shear is going
to be replaced at the end of the week by
the winner of the conservative
leadership race that race wraps up on
sunday
and it will be up to that new leader
along with the leaders of the ndp in the
block quebecois
to decide if they want to vote
non-confidence after that throne speech
and that would force a fall election as
for trudeau
he's counting on that confidence vote
and he expects
to win it robin david aiken in ottawa
thanks david
for more on the prime minister's
strategy in pro-rogan parliament
let's bring in our ottawa bureau chief
mercedes stevenson mercedes why would
trudeau
open himself up to a confidence vote
well he almost seemed to be daring the
opposition didn't he robin
and it felt like we were right back into
last fall out on the campaign trail
that was very much a campaign style
speech he's not talking about small
changes
he's using the term transformative
change
strategic vision huge changes to the
canadian economy and the way
the liberal government governs all of
those things signaling that he's moving
to the left with some of these policies
and that means he's probably quite safe
because it means negotiations
with the ndp there was hints at more
green
care and green economy child care seem
to be being hinted at repeatedly by both
freeland
and trudeau and those are things that
the ndp has said they want in the greens
and as long as they have those two
parties
they can stay in power mercedes it's
clear trudeau is trying to turn the page
on the wii controversy what does
pro-roguing parliament mean for those
ongoing investigations
well it will shut those investigations
down the committees will no longer be
meeting to question people
question witnesses but there will still
be documents i asked prime minister
trudeau about that and he said the 5 000
pages that we're all waiting to see
that reveal how these decisions about we
were made
have been released and will be
eventually available
once the committee has dug through them
but it certainly puts the heat
that is on the government on pause and
all of this
has what has led us to this point
including bill morneau's departure
the prime minister offered few details
when asked about bill morneau's
departure today what more
are you hearing about the lead-up to his
resignation
well robin we haven't heard any more
about why bill morneau resigned but
people aren't buying the line that the
finance minister suddenly had a
revelation
mid-pandemic and mid-economic crisis as
this government finds its way forward
we do know that christian freeland has
said that she is confident in her
ability to say no to the prime minister
and not afraid to do so and has done so
before
but he needed somebody who was willing
to go forward with a new and very
different agenda than that of bill
mourinho's and you can see that in the
kind of policies
that they're already talking about
mercedes stevenson in ottawa thanks
mercedes
this is not the first time trudeau has
lost a key cabinet minister
nor is the wii charity controversy his
first run-in with the ethics
commissioner
in our next story eric sorensen looks at
where all of this leaves the prime
minister
and his minority government it's been a
confident unself-conscious government
that has tackled the kovit-19 pandemic
but the vanishing act of the minister of
finance during a health and economic
crisis
is a gut punch to a governing party in a
minority parliament
the opposition pouncing on a prime
minister suddenly vulnerable
over ethics again we still have the same
corrupt and incompetent prime minister
ahead of the same corrupt and chaotic
government previous prime ministers have
confronted memorable scandals
stephen harper over senator mike duffy's
expenses
paul martin with the quebec sponsorship
program that began under his predecessor
jean cretien
and brian mulroney over airbus and
payments once he was out of office
but justin trudeau has been on a
comparatively fast track of questionable
conduct
gifts from the agga khan in 2016 the
snc-lavalanche controversy that cost him
two senior ministers just last year
and now the wii charity scandal that
ensnared him
and his finance minister the three times
that the prime minister has been
investigated by
the ethics commissioner have all been
i would say kind of unforced errors on
his part that it's not
necessarily that there's some deep issue
of corruption with the government
that seems to be where he gets caught is
his his own
um kind of personal stewardship of his
office
where does this leave the minority
government the liberals at 156 seats are
short of the 170 needed to govern
comfortably with a majority
any one of the main opposition parties
can prop up the government
but it would take all three together
with over 170 seats to bring the
government down
sooner or later we're going in the exact
opposite direction right now under
justin trudeau
the conservatives are just days away
from choosing a new leader
their wish to vote no confidence seems
only a matter of time
and the bloc quebecois leader suggests
the government may not survive its own
throne
speech that puts the ndp and jugmeet
singh in a pivotal position
a party that's never formed government
doesn't want to squander the leverage it
now has
the job of parliament is to work for
people to make sure they have help in a
pandemic we need to be there to do that
work
and so that's what we're going to
continue to fight for a normally quiet
first
summer after an election has become
politically agitated
as another election may already be
coming into view
eric sorensen global news toronto
all of this happened against the
backdrop of canada coping with the kova
19 pandemic
and as new cases are on the rise in
parts of the country
ontario recorded 125 new infections
its highest single day increase in
positive tests
since july 31st quebec had 46.
the good news is that it's the fifth
consecutive day with fewer than 100
cases in that province
manitoba had 17 but in the west both bc
and
alberta saw more than 80 cases each in
the past 24 hours
the kofi 19 curve is veering upward
again
in large part by infections among
younger people ages 20 to 39.
health officials in alberta and b.c are
stepping up their efforts
to inform that age group that the risk
to them and
others is real jennifer palmer reports
a day at the beach a great way to beat
the summer heat but crowds pose a danger
as infections
increase it's outside there's a lot of
space fresh air i think
it's a little bit safer than being
inside i hope youth out there
are taking it very seriously because if
we
don't respect it it could get out of
control covet 19 numbers are hitting
record highs
in british columbia and alberta both
provinces seeing hundreds of new cases
being recorded over the past few days
with a recent surge in new cases being
driven primarily by young adults aged
20 to 39. young people really can get
very sick
and die young people can be really
severely affected by this disease
and i don't want that to get overlooked
i never thought i would get it so
anything is possible 26 year old vince
lee was hit hard by the virus
he's a fitness instructor and practices
mixed martial arts
he had no underlying health conditions
and managed type 2 diabetes through diet
and exercise i didn't have a lot of time
after the x-ray i was just put under a
medically induced coma
immediately so i didn't have time to
think i was just more
panicking that i saw ventilators i was
like oh
it's happening this is real we've all
heard about a second wave in particular
in the fall but is it here now
numbers are spiking and flu season is
weeks away
is this the start of wave two is this a
continuation of wave one
i think it's almost an academic
discussion the point is
that we're having a significant rise
in cases it's a new normal all of us
have to navigate as the virus hits peaks
and valleys potentially through
20 22. covet is going to be with us for
a long time what i'm hoping is that
through a combination
of treatments hopefully a vaccine
and and better testing technology
it can become the background noise
and not the thing that dominates the
news headlines jennifer palma global
news
vancouver a dangerous journey caught on
camera
coming up this is no place for a little
boy on a bike
now to a story that turned heads on a
busy highway in hamilton ontario
but it could have easily turned tragic
take a look
police intercepted a six-year-old biker
riding shirtless
down highway 403 he left his
grandparents house
desperate to visit his mom in toronto
several drivers called police concerned
for the boy's safety
fortunately officers tracked him down
within seven minutes
tonight a canadian researcher is
providing advice on whether kids should
head back to the classroom
dr stephen friedman has been studying
the impact of kova 19 on kids around the
world
and plans to send his own children to
school next month
as heather yorks west reports he says to
weigh the decision
carefully and keep medical evidence in
mind
chris faulkner has decided to send his
four and a half-year-old daughter to
preschool this fall
but he still has concerns lots of
concern i don't feel like
our provincial government is doing much
if
anything to to sort of help parents and
it's really frustrating and
frightening back to school is fraught
with anxiety for many
parents but a canadian researcher
studying covet 19 and kids
believes the medical evidence should
ease some of those fears
i have two kids and my kids are
returning to school in september
dr steven friedman's research looks at
how covet 19 has impacted children
in 13 different countries and while his
studies data has not yet been analyzed
friedman says we already know
kids have a very low risk of becoming
seriously ill from the virus
most children have mild illness and we
don't think they tend to have
significant long-term complications and
severe illness is exceedingly rare in
children
the bigger concern however is over kids
spreading the illness to vulnerable
family members
after months apart grandmother jennifer
goldate is finally spending time with
her grandkids
but she says she'd likely have to keep
her distance if they went back to school
i have friends that work in schools and
so they're in their 50s and 60s now and
maybe kids mostly don't get too sick
but that doesn't mean they're not gonna
get sick we still
don't know how well children transmit
covid19
especially if they're asymptomatic
friedman plans to tackle that question
in a separate study launching later this
month
evidence has shown however that public
health measures can lower the risk of
virus spread
i'm a big advocate of mandatory masking
i think the emphasis
also needs to be on hand washing or
sanitizer and maintaining and keeping
vigilance that those are being done very
very frequently throughout the day
he also recommends parents make sure
their kids get flu
shots this year because we don't know
the impact of co-infections
and freeman says there's a possibility
kids could become
seriously ill if infected with a
combination of the seasonal flu
and covet 19. heather urex west global
news
calgary there are developments tonight
in july's cyber attack on the royal
military college of canada
documents that were apparently hacked
have appeared on the dark web in the
past week
global news has viewed the files
including financial documents like tax
receipts
as well as what appears to be budgets
for various departments of the college
the leak is believed to be the result of
a type of ransomware called
doppelpamer which infiltrates an
organization's system
and steals its data nobody knows who's
behind the attack
the department of national defense has
yet to confirm the leaked documents
contain royal military college of canada
information still ahead the verdict in
the assassination of lebanon's former
prime minister
you're watching global national
[Music]
a 6.6 magnitude earthquake has left a
wake of destruction in the philippines
killing at least one person and injuring
dozens
with a depth of 30 kilometers it's the
most powerful quake to hit
in eight months a hospital and a
makeshift coronavirus quarantine center
are among the damaged buildings the
philippines lies in what is known as the
ring of fire
an arc of faults around the pacific
ocean where most of the world's
earthquakes
occur an update on the ecological
disaster near
mauritius officials have arrested the
captain of a bulk carrier that ran
aground last month causing
more than a thousand tons of oil to
spill into the pristine waters off the
island
the japanese owned vessel broke apart on
sunday
three weeks after it struck a coral reef
the ship's indian captain is facing
charges under piracy and maritime
violence act
his second in command is also in custody
an investigation is ongoing
cleanup crews are still working to limit
the impact on the environmentally
sensitive area
there is an apparent military mutiny
underway in the west african nation of
mali raising concerns of a coup d'etat
soldiers from a base
outside the capital were seen patrolling
the streets after reports they had taken
up arms
and detained the country's prime
minister and president
in bamako scores of anti-government
protesters celebrated the rumored
toppling of the country's leadership
the government has been in crisis for
months with the economy on the verge of
collapse
and a worsening security situation
canadian peacekeepers had been deployed
in mali until last year
a contingent of about 10 canadian forces
personnel
remains in the capital all are safe
and accounted for a member of the
lebanese militant group
hezbollah has been found guilty in the
assassination of lebanon's former prime
minister
rafiq hariri a u.n backed tribunal
convicted saleem
ayash for his involvement in a truck
bombing that killed hariri and 21 others
in 2005. three other hezbollah members
were acquitted
all were tried in absentia and none is
in custody
the tribunal says it was a politically
motivated attack
and designed to destabilize lebanon but
did not direct
responsibility beyond ayash the trial
chamber is of the view that
syria and hezbollah may have had motives
to eliminate mr
hariri and some of his political allies
however there was no evidence that this
hezbollah leadership
had any involvement in mr hariri's
murder
and there is no direct evidence of
syrian involvement in it
hariri's murder ignited a wave of
protests that saw
syria withdraw from lebanon after nearly
three decades
hezbollah however has seen its political
influence grow
since that time and it wields
significant power in government today
the verdict after a five-year-long
investigation
was delayed nearly two weeks following
the catastrophic explosion
at beirut's port up next the canadian
effort to help families and children
struggling in beirut
the recovery in lebanon could take years
and in many cases
life in beirut may never get back to
normal after so many died
during that huge port explosion as
crystal gomezing reports canadian aid
organizations are doing all they can to
help
and provide hope aid agencies by the
dozens are coordinating efforts for food
shelter
and the rebuilding of a city it is a
mammoth
task and at the center of it a desire to
help
tiny still trembling hearts
oh man and aisha know their boys are
hurting
she says her son is now scared of
everything and
everyone the syrian family escaped to
lebanon for safety
the blast on august 4th at the beirut
port chore through their home
one hundred thousand children are
estimated to have been directly affected
by the explosion
another six hundred thousand indirectly
lebanon's prime minister and cabinet
resigned but
that hasn't silenced demands for justice
it was a massacre
it's a crime that happened tracy were
kept on on telling
alexus they tried to kill us
show them that you can be the miracle of
this tragedy and that you can and wake
up
three and a half-year-old alexandra
najar died
her family has connections to montreal
and was getting ready to move in
september
people in canada are doing what they can
to help
yes at the checkout that the cashiers
they're asking if you want to donate
a lot of people are personal donations
are being matched by the federal
government
up to 5 million dollars until august
24th
save the children is one of 12 agencies
helping to organize donations to support
those working on the ground
it's a shocking experience for children
lots of trauma
and this in a place lebanon where a week
before the
explosion we had released an analysis
that said that half a million children
five hundred thousand in beirut
were struggling to survive already now
survival
is the focus many are just trying to
make it through the day
crystal gamson global news london
and that is global national for this
tuesday i'm robin gill tonight your
canada is lawrencetown beach just
east of dartmouth nova scotia we'd love
to see your corner of this country
so please email your photos to viewers
at globalnational.com
thank you for watching and i'll see you
back here tomorrow have a great night